[Music]
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it it can fit
12 cards with cash on the back using a
clip like this one or a strap we've got
one for the whole team I've got one
Francis has one even our producer Anthem
has one but he's from Liverpool so he
flogged his on the black market the
great thing about Ridge is that they
give you a lifetime guarantee which
means if you want you can have only one
wallet for the rest of your life Rich
are so confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallets that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because rigs are such great guys
are going to give of you ten percent off
and free worldwide shipping and returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridge.com forward slash
trigger and use our special code which
is of course trigger
hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a Canadian lawyer who's
been covering the Canadian Freedom
Convoy and the trucker issue very very
well over the last few weeks a lot of
you have asked us to bring them on so
please with no further Ado welcome
vivofride David good to have you thanks
for coming on gentlemen thank you for
having me I consider myself to be mildly
interesting not fascinating but thank
you nonetheless all right well we'll see
what we can do about that before we get
cracking a little bit of housekeeping
for everybody watching and listening uh
we're gonna do about 45 minutes to 50
minutes with David we're going to have a
great conversation about what's been
happening and then there will be an
opportunity uh for you guys to submit
your questions if you want to do that
the best way to do it is uh send a super
chat or send the PayPal the links are in
the description and they'll be appearing
in the chat as well
I'm concentrating
my mic is on
all right okay
uh you haven't been able to hear us for
the last minute okay we heard it was
just softer than friends it was just
soft day it wasn't the usual Francis
voice so what I'm saying is if you want
to submit a question for for David as we
talk uh there will be an opportunity to
do that the way to do that is through
the super chats or the paypals and it is
not an episode of trigonometry David if
we haven't [ __ ] something up
technologically before we start so we're
good to go all right well here we go
let's start the conversation so David
the question we always ask our guests in
the very first one is who are you what
has been your journey through life but
the third part of that question is how
did you get involved with the truckers
and the situation that's happening in
Canada the world life is amazingly
bizarre Kierkegaard said it can only be
understood backwards but has to be lived
forwards uh montrealer born and raised
youngest of five kids my father is a
lawyer my second oldest brother is a
lawyer my sister is a lawyer my other
brother's a lawyer I'm a lawyer are you
Jewish well I am Jewish as well born
that makes sense it was either you go
into law or you go into medicine and uh
you know I was too late to jump back on
the science wagon so I went into law
um born and raised studied philosophy at
McGill always had a thing about
videography always loved making videos
when we were kids we had you know the
the VHS camcorder on the shoulders we
would make videos on the weekend in it's
something called sage up in between high
school and University I did fine arts
studied philosophy but then you have to
go out and get a professional degree and
get a job so I went to a law school in
French in Quebec City uh got my law
degree got a job at a big Law Firm
worked there for you ever take five
years as a student stagger young lawyer
had my first kid said I don't like this
lifestyle I don't like the practice of
law all that much I quit on a Friday
afternoon said I'm gonna go back to
photography at Dawson college and get my
commercial photography degree before I
could even apply ultimately you know
didn't get in I started getting calls
for people who needed a lawyer I was
like okay I can do some work by the end
of the summer I had more work than I
knew what to do with and then I started
my own solo practice which over the next
seven years built up into a nice
Boutique litigation firm but lo and
behold seven years later I did not like
the practice of law anymore
uh any more than I did at any point in
my life and then in the interim I
discovered YouTube I got a GoPro for
Christmas in February 2014 started
making videos and started you know
getting back into the childhood passion
of making videos long story short one
video went viral once upon a time I
learned about viral videography video
licensing and then it all just merged
together where I took video editing
content creation and merged it with my
expertise 13 plus years as a commercial
litigator and started doing legal
analysis on current events how I got a
trucker thing I I'm sitting there I I
had the channel was a big enough Channel
beforehand I was covering law did the
impeachment did The Rittenhouse trial
Alec Baldwin all these current events
legal stuff uh and then I'm looking at
what's happening in Ottawa and hearing
about it
through the media but also from
first-hand people on site and I'm saying
I can't reconcile the diverging stories
that I'm getting from mainstream
Canadian media CBC CTV a racist
xenophobic violent protest and people on
the ground saying it's nothing like this
so I go down the Monday after the
protest just to live stream I said I'm
gonna live stream for as long as my
battery lasts if some if I see Nazi
Flags the world will see it if I see
Confederate flags the world will see it
if we see violence vandalism the world
will see it in real time and the world
saw what was happening in real time and
it wasn't anything like that and I just
said I'm going to go back every day
document this so the world can see the
degree to which media and politicians
are lying to Canadians to demonize this
protest for reasons which in retrospect
now we can totally understand why they
did it and that entire movement blew up
into something of an international
movement
um and I mean it's it was phenomenal to
watch it happen in real time because lot
of people really just got awakened to
the fact that we are being lied to in
our faces remorselessly by this Vortex
of of fake I call it fake news but just
political lies you got the media running
lies the politicians recycle the media
lies the media recycles the politicians
amplification of the lies and that's
your Vortex of misinformation all right
well uh let's try and diffuse some of
that misinformation as a fellow Jewish
Nazi uh let me uh let me start by saying
for those of you because you talk about
the Canadians are being lied to but
actually all of us around the world
we've got absolutely no idea what's
going on I think a lot of people sort of
pretend that they do but we don't know
what's happened uh it's hard to follow
from abroad when you can't go down and
see with your own eyes and what do you
trust and what do you not trust so let's
just go right back to the very beginning
how did this happen what was it about
what happened how did it start how did
it proceed so it it started so
innocuously I've I have my chat Channel
I've had my channel for a long time and
I've been doing what I call Viva on the
street rants of sorts I walk my dog it
started a year ago during the Viva on
the streets started a year ago where we
were under curfew and the only way to
get out of your house after eight
o'clock was to walk your dog and so I
said I'm gonna document this curfew
because I think it's unconstitutional I
think it's obscene and I started doing
these these videos on the street where I
just talked about legal stuff that was
going on in Canada specifically in the
in respect of the covet response uh so
I've been doing this for a while and
I've been doing them again during the
second lockdown you know the very
scientific government implemented a
second curfew a year after the first
highly unscientific curfew and as I'm
doing it you know there starts to be
some discussion about this this Convoy
that is leaving British Columbia to
protest these absurd covet measures and
I started looking into it it's like okay
well I'm not seeing anything I'm seeing
a report in the CBC about hundreds of
truckers a convoy and in British
Columbia I think they were going from
Surrey to Vancouver which are two cities
in British Columbia for those of you who
don't know west coast of Canada and I
was like okay well so big deal they're
protesting road conditions apparently
then I you know I get a lot of Intel
from people who know more than me emails
saying dude that's not right there it's
a bigger Convoy it's thousands of
truckers driving across the country
and sure enough once it became so known
that it couldn't be hidden the CBC which
was originally reporting on a very small
hundreds of trucks coming out of British
Columbia protesting road conditions they
stealth edit their original article to
just add the small detail that protest
or Convoy is not the same one as the
Convoy that's going cross-country to
Ottawa and then it just it kept on
getting bigger and bigger the media
tried to ignore it then they tried to
spin it by saying it's a small protest
in British Columbia and then when it
became too big to ignore they tried to
malign it and that's when we saw all of
the misinformation racist xenophobic
they're coming to overthrow the
government they're coming to quote
overthrow the government that statement
was quoted by jagmeet Singh then by the
National Post then by daytime radio when
in reality nobody involved in the actual
Convoy itself ever had any stated
objective to overthrow the government
but I mean that's how it started and
then the question is look how it's going
now I mean it it so that is sorry David
that's where we are now okay
I've been watching Canada now before
covid hit Canada I thought Canada was
one of the most liberal sane countries
in the entire world and I've looked at
Canada and the way it's behaved over
covert I'm going to use technical
language here it's [ __ ] mental right
it's absolutely insane why why have the
Canadians done this or more accurately
why are the Canadian government
implemented this and why have they
behaved in this fashion well you know
it's funny uh I again things can be
understood backwards I had a lot of
people on my channel back when I was you
know giving I still think they're
objective breakdowns but I was not
sharing my opinion I was you know
explaining things back in the day all of
my American Subs were saying you guys
have this is pre-covered you guys have
no free speech in Canada you have no
freedoms in Canada you are subjects of
of of the queen and you think you have
freedom and I'm sitting there saying you
guys are exaggerating we have freedom of
speech you know and then I didn't
appreciate it until I did a video on
Bill c16 at the time which was uh uh
Jordan Peterson was talking about it is
this law going to result in compelled
speech and he was he was raising the
flags about it at the time and I was
like no no it's not you know we want to
add gender identity as aggravating
factors to hate crimes Jordan Peterson
was saying well this is going to result
in people saying you call me by my
gender identity or it's a hate crime or
I'm a you know compelled speech I was
like no no you're exaggerating but it
was it started long before you know the
liberal policies under Justin Trudeau
have have been fundamentally illiberable
illiberal but cloaked under liberalism
the idea of banning certain types of
speech that you deem to be hate speech
well it starts off with certain I call
them objective words and then it turns
into Hong Kong memes means Heil Hitler
and you can't say it because that's how
it goes so it's always these seeds have
been planted a long time ago and the
analogy everybody says bamboo grows over
overnight bamboo might grow 18 feet
overnight but it took six years for
those seeds to to take the seed in the
ground so it could grow that fast
overnight we went fascistic over the
last two years but those seeds had been
planted unbeknownst to a great many
people at the very least as of Justin
Trudeau's Ascension to the Reign of
Power and you know not only were we not
paying attention to it at the time
because we could not have anticipated it
would go so far off the rails we were
also ignoring
the the dictator's own Tendencies to
praise dictatorships and uh his
propensity for corruption and lack of
Ethics David you're using some big words
there but and sort of the Normie audio
portion of our audience I think would
walk at some of that you call it
fascistic you know you and I probably
have you know members of our family who
died to Fascism in in World War II you
called Justin Trudeau dictate are you
not going a bit farther are you not
exaggerating like explain to us why is
this fascistic uh so I've I've had this
argument with with friends and family
where you know they say I don't compare
it to Germany don't compare it to this
and that and I I'm very much I agree
with that you don't willy-nilly just you
know break out the Godwin's law and when
someone makes a rule call them Hitler uh
and and I've been specifying this over
time when anyone Compares things to
Hitler or Germany they think 1939 to
1945 Germany but there are other eras in
which you can compare uh without getting
into the most egregious part of Nazi
Germany starting with 1933 the reichstag
fire where whether or not it was a false
flag set up it was used as an excuse to
invoke the emergencies act and suspend
Parliament so a fabricated crisis was
used to Grant the government emergency
powers to effectively suspend democracy
if that is not exactly what was done now
well then I don't care if you get
offended by the analogy you should at
least know your history so that you can
see the signs of things as they're
occurring in real time I doubt very much
Canada will ever descend into a 1939
Germany but that does not mean that
Canada under Trudeau is not right now
acting very much like a 1933 Germany
because they are so when I use the term
fascistic
um a government subsidizing the media
buying off the media so the media then
effectively becomes the mouthpiece of
the government and then you have the
courts who are appointed by the
government
ratifying these decisions that are made
by the government uh promoted by the
media yeah to brainwash the masses into
thinking it's somehow acceptable to talk
about attacks on the unvaccinated or
it's somehow acceptable to quarantine to
forcefully detain people in government
facilities with no due process no court
order no nothing when all those three
things come together you basically have
a fascistic regime whether or not you
find it hyperbolic that's that's the
literal Mussolini definition of fascism
is when you have big Tech and the media
working with the government and that is
exactly what we have now to violate our
most fundamental and sacred rights
people should understand this outside of
Canada
within Canada during the co during the
covid response we were literally locked
in our homes at least in Quebec under a
curfew from eight at night to it might
have been eight at night to five in the
morning or Nine and Nine whatever the
time was We were put under curfew to
fight a virus when our own health
director guy here Horatio Aruda openly
stated there's no science to back this
as a measure to combat a virus we were
locked in our homes the court said
that's not a big deal uh there was
another lawsuit where they were
contesting children being compelled to
wear face masks the court said the risk
however minimal is still there so we're
ratifying this in Canada Justin Trudeau
required uh travel as re-entering by air
to be uh quizzed off to
government-designated quarantine
facilities they called them quarantine
hotels but they were taken and detained
in government designated quarantine
facilities no due process no and they
had to pay for the luxury no less 2
thousand dollars uh where people were
sexually assaulted in these government
designated quarantine facilities the
court said that's fine so I don't think
people outside of Canada appreciate how
far off the rails the Canadian
government has gone but they have their
bought and paid for media promoting The
Narrative concealing the lies concealing
everything else that is is wrong with
the Justin Trudeau government
all the while just wholesale desecration
of our most fundamental constitutional
rights and if anyone gets offended by
the comparisons to other historical
atrocities out of New Brunswick they
implemented something where they were
basically saying unvaccinated people
could not get into grocery stores and
they would have to find alternative
means for uh I think they called them
necessities of life
I'm sorry if you don't think it's time
to start making comparisons to
historical atrocities when you are
denying people access to necessities of
life based on their medical status you
need to learn from history and I don't
need to weigh my words
here's the thing hang on a second but
isn't he the wokest kind prime minister
that you've ever had he says amen he
says Hey women you know he's the first
black prime minister of Canada of Canada
come on he's he's he he's a He's a
hypocrite he lies period he he totes
himself as when he was asked you know
why is your cabinet uh why are there so
many women in your cabinet and he says
because it's 20 20. hahaha well done he
took social media credit he scored his
virtue signaling points for appointing
he touted it at the time the first
female Aboriginal Minister of Justice
and attorney general he took social
media credit for being Progressive for
having done that and then when she Jody
Wilson raybould the Minister of Justice
refused to adhere to his corrupt demands
not to prosecute this massive
conglomerate that he was chummy chummy
with when she as an independent Minister
of Justice said I'm going to prosecute
them for corruption uh because of what
they were doing in Liberia it's a
construction conglomerate he pressured
her not to do it he pressured her to
enter into a deferred prosecution
agreement with this company she said no
I'm I'm Prosecuting them and then he who
took social media virtue signaling
credit for having appointed the first
female Aboriginal Minister of Justice
demoted her because she would not listen
to his corrupt demands I mean he talks
the talk and he says you know the
platitudes but in practice he does
everything the exact opposite and you
know the the blackface thing the images
everybody now has seen across the world
it's you know I would not have been
shocked about that because people do
stupid things uh the the moral climate
when he did that was different than what
it is today but it's the hypocrisy that
this guy looks around and sees racism
everywhere he sees sexism everywhere he
sees you know what he sees bad things
everywhere and it's probably because
it's all in him and he just views the
world through his own mental framework
of feeling that and doing that himself
so he just assumes everyone else does it
but the blackface images he was alleged
to have groped a reporter back in 2000
he apologized to her he fired the
minister of Justice for not adhering to
his demands his two ethics breaches I
don't know if your audience knows that
Justin Trudeau was found to have
breached his the code of ethics or the
ethics code twice on two separate
occasions one for taking undisclosed
gifts from the Aga Khan foundation while
that uh Aga Khan foundation was
petitioning the government for tens of
millions of dollars in federal monies
that they got he took at all expenses
weekend vacation to the private island
of Aga Khan didn't disclose it brought
down the RCMP of course didn't disclose
any of that and was found to have
breached his ethics that was the first
time second time was the snc lava Lane
where he exercised undue pressure on the
independent body of the Minister of
Justice and attorney general and then
the third ethics investigation was his
mother and his brother taking speaking
fees from this thing called the we
charity where they took like 335
thousand dollars in speaking fees from a
charity over two years and then lo and
behold the Wii charity was granted a
sole source no bid government contract
to administer a billion dollars in
student aid for which they would have
gotten paid 20 million dollars I don't
know how that did not satisfy the
criteria for a third ethics violation
but there was that and while that
investigation is going on he provokes
Parliament to suspend the investigation
I mean he he might say the right things
but everything he does is the exact
opposite and um he's ultimately just a
pure hypocrite mildly he does sound like
he'd make a great prime minister of
Russia the way you were talking about
him but uh it's it's interesting that
you you're saying this because
the people of Canada some of them seem
to be supporting him
here's the funny thing so I ran for
federal office last uh September I think
that might have been the last time I cut
my hair I ran for federal office for the
PPC The People's Party of Canada you
know they're they're dubbed far right uh
more conservative than conservative it's
an it's an idiotic misnomer because I
don't consider myself conservative I
don't know what these words mean anymore
but I have as many liberal uh policies
in my in my spirit as I do conservative
I ran I didn't meet one person who liked
Justin Trudeau I met a bunch of people
who said I hate him I'm going to vote
for him and hold my nose like they said
with Hillary Clinton I met a bunch who
said I hate him so much I'm going to
vote NDP out of protest the new
Democratic party uh led by jagmeet Singh
and I said at the time if you think
that's a protest vote I mean you're just
voting for Justin Trudeau 2.0 the only
difference between Justin Trudeau and
jagmeet Singh Is that jagmi Singh has
not had the power yet to act on his
corruption but he's just as corrupt and
just as immoral for for your audience
who doesn't know the new Democratic
party the leader jagmeet Singh at one
point during the election came out and
said
uh the people who don't want to wear
masks tend to be far right extremists
one second we just lost audio on our end
for some reason here we go here we go
uh yeah carry on carry on okay apologize
uh jagmeet Singh for anybody who doesn't
know he's the leader of the new
Democratic party during the election he
came out in a speech very eloquently
said people who oppose mask mandates and
don't want to wear masks are selfish
they don't care about Community they
tend to be right-wing extremists the
most idiotic stuff in the world you can
imagine and then about a week later he
was caught not wearing a mask breaking
the coveted rules so jagmeet Singh Is is
just as bad as Trudeau minus the power
so he has not yet had the chance to be
in power to act on his corrupt nature
but people I never met anybody who like
Justin Trudeau uh so I don't he got
re-elected with a minority government I
think they they lost or gained one seat
but there was no difference but it
wasn't like 20 or 22 percent of the
eligible vote voted for Trudeau the rest
was split over the NDP the conservatives
uh to a lesser extent the PPC we got
under a million votes Nationwide which
was still pretty good and then the green
party and some other stuff but I some
people vote for him out of pure
ignorance some people vote for him
because they think if they vote for a
liberal party it makes them liberal But
the irony is that the liberal party and
Justin Trudeau are the most intolerant
uh I would say undemocratic and
unconstitutional party out there they
just go under the name liberal so people
can feel good about themselves I guess
so let me just follow up I guess what
I'm guessing out David is is to what
extent is he imposing policies that have
public support because in the UK there
were moments when we were going in our
fascistic Direction
and what we found was that was because a
lot of the public wanted it
is that true in Canada it's it's a
difficult thing to tell because you know
he he comes out during the election just
as Justin Trudeau and says how the
unvaccinated they're putting their kids
at risk and they're putting our kids at
risk and then he goes out to even say
something even worse those people are
putting us all at risk he says these
things they get outraged but then you
get these polls from CBC you know using
the same pollsters that that had the PPC
at under two percent which made no sense
you get these pollsters who are
fundamentally corrupt for anybody who
doesn't really understand that I would
invite you to watch the sidebar that I
did with Robert Barnes with Richard
Barris
um pollsters are notoriously corrupt but
when you have the CBC coming out and
saying 70 of Canadians support harsher
measures on the unvaccinated and then
and then you go look and it's like a
polling of 14 not even 1100 people who
anybody who answers to these polls in
the first place tends to be of a certain
ideological alignment you have the media
running these polls that say people
agree with this when I don't think they
do and my impression is that these
corrupt pollsters in the first place are
trying to craft reality and not reflect
it
um and then you have daytime radio cjd
saying you know people support more
measures we should crack down on the
unvaccinated my impression is the
majority of people don't feel this way
but the pollsters and CBC the state
funded media come out and say the
majority of people do feel this way as
though to empower others or to encourage
them to feel this way based on polls
that say everybody feels it's a vicious
circle but my personal impression is
that most people don't and a lot of them
are just too fearful to say publicly
that they don't I can't even share
anecdotes of professionals from all
walks of life who come to me and say
Canada's off the deep end what's up with
this we can't stand this but uh when you
have like eight political parties
running for office it has its own
problems that a two-party system doesn't
have in that it splits up the vote
Justin Trudeau gets reelected with a
very small minority government and he
gets to say I have a mandate to do this
stuff when I think in reality he doesn't
and I think beneath the the veneer of
fake news and fake pools people do not
support this and people despise it
why do you think it is that the more
liberal and I'm putting liberals in
inverted commas because as you've just
said to yourself these words no longer
mean that what they're used to and in
fact many of them have become redundant
I think that's a great Point why is it
these Liberals are actually the most
Draconian when it comes to implementing
covid legislation you look at Scotland
with the SMP very liberal but they're
not they're a really really hard line
when it comes to covert you look at
what's happening in New York you look at
what's happening in Canada you look at
what's happening in New Zealand these
are countries that have gone off the
deep end when it comes to this when it
comes to this virus
there's these I I don't like
categorizing People based on politics I
just remember you know growing up this
did not come from my father so I don't
know what anyone thinking this came from
my father uh I remember always hearing
liberalism as a mental disorder uh I
remember hearing behind every liberal is
an aspiring Tyrant I never understood
these things at the time but now I see
it it's that the lit is it's the idea
that uh who was it that wrote through
the Looking Glass Lewis Carroll I think
it was his quote who basically said
there's nothing worse than a tyrant who
thinks that they're acting on their own
benevolence because they'll they'll do
it day in and day out and there's no
respite to their tyranny because they
think it's for the the good of others
you know Justin I don't I I don't even
think that applies to Trudeau because I
think he knows what he's doing but the
bottom line is they think that it's for
everyone else's benefits so there's no
limits to their liberalism because it's
for everyone else's own greater good but
it is it's just a shocking irony you
know in the United States you have the
Democrats the Democratic party saying
you can't have voter ID because it's
racist but you need vaccine passport ID
to get into a coffee shop or to eat in
New York City I mean you you have and I
called it at the time I called it out at
the time when Justin Trudeau was saying
you know the most liberal tolerant
government it's all about inclusion
diversity Etc implementing a vaccine
passport system that that is desperately
going to impact blacks Latinos and
indigenous people of Canada and if you
don't know it you're you're in you're an
incompetent nincompoop if you do know it
you're an absolute hypocrite and it's
not possible that Justin Trudeau does
not know that the people who are
historically reluctant to to have
vaccine hesitancy
are uh ethnic minorities and the
ultimate irony the reason for which they
are reluctant is because of past
historical atrocities committed by the
government the Tuskegee experiments on
the black population in America the
residential schooling system in Canada
for which our liberal government just
apologized and paid out 40 billion
settlement they tested they did medical
testing on on indigenous children in the
residential school system and now you
got your liberal government once again
saying we know what's better for you
minorities do what we say or you can't
fly on a plane or take a train across
Canada I mean they think they're doing
it for other people's good they are
aspiring tyrants and they try to cloak
their tyranny in benevolence and it's
the most dangerous combination but it's
the most absolute flagrant hypocrisy you
may as well just put up a sign in your
in your restaurant if you're imposing a
vaccine passport saying black people
Latinos and Indigenous proportionately
are not welcome that's what's happening
in New York and the inconsistency in
these policies should be shocking to
everyone who considers themselves to be
a liberal or a Democrat
look I'm fully behind you and both of us
and everyone here at trigonometry has
spoken out consistency consistently
against vaccine passports I think the
people who agreed to them you're opening
a Pandora's Box and if you're opening a
Pandora's Box to a place into a society
where none of us want to go
that being the case what's let's look at
the trucker situation now what is
happening now on the ground as of today
the last I mean Ottawa is effectively uh
at last checked a police state I mean if
they thought if the people of Ottawa
thought that their Mobility through
downtown Ottawa was compromised by the
Convoy well be careful what you wish for
because now you got cops and fences on
every street corner uh literally
checking papers checking credentials to
walk through the downtown court
um it's it's a misnomer it's the fake
news uh success of this the public
perception of this protest that Ottawa
was besieged that Ottawa was crippled
and paralyzed I drove in it was if not
14 days 13 days it's between 12 and 4 I
forget how many I never once had any
traffic getting in or out I never once
had any problem finding parking I parked
a kilometer away from the protest maybe
about a Colorado never had a problem
walking through never had security
issues never felt unsafe never felt
threatened or intimidated there was not
one lick of vandalism anywhere in the
protest which was on you know
concentrated it on Wellington Street
which is right on Parliament Hill and
the three blocks uh to the South
people are saying that the city's
paralyzed it's besieged it's an
occupation restaurants could have been
open they could have been open easily
and safely and they would have done very
good business it was the government that
told them to shut down and the
businesses that stayed open did very
well and after The Siege was over the
government apparently is going after one
of the coffee shops the iconic Cafe who
served truckers during the protest but
during the protest
free Mobility
Ottawa had never been safer and this is
if anyone doesn't trust me go Google it
crime actually went down in the weeks of
the Convoy because for those who don't
know Ottawa does have a bit of a
homeless problem it does have a bit of
it's not the cleanest city it's not the
safest city and that area was not an
area that you'd ever want to walk at
night under normal times
but then you know the cops show up after
three weeks of the most peaceful protest
and they break it up in the most brutal
brutal manner possible the videos are
out there
and then it becomes a total plea it's
cordoned off cops are checking
credentials passports only if you work
in the downtown Cork and you go there so
the people of Ottawa if you thought it
was blocked off before uh you know look
at it now I haven't gone back since the
Saturday of the day where it was clear
that it was going to be broken up the
cops were not were not friendly they
were breaking out tear gas they were
hitting people with batons they were
pepper spraying people I was personally
within 10 feet of a stun grenade going
off or whatever the reason two of them
sorry two went off for whatever the
reason I haven't gone back since
um but I mean I've seen the images and
I've seen Rebel news there it's it's an
outright police state it might have been
it might be less so now that Justin
Trudeau rescinded the emergencies act
that he declared and voted on two days
ago and David one of the things that I
think is immediately striking to anyone
who didn't wake up yesterday but has
been paying attention to what's going on
you use the phrase peaceful protest uh
we do remember only a couple of years
ago there were protests around the world
uh whose peacefulness was somewhat uh
more questionable let's say to put it
very mildly there were shops being
looted shops being burned people being
assaulted several people were murdered
uh whole territories of American cities
were annexed as if by a foreign power
and occupied uh why do you think it's
okay to you know
for Mounted Police to trample protesters
who are protesting against vaccine
passports and vaccine mandates but it
wasn't okay for the police to do
anything in fact the solution and your
leader kneeled with BLM the solution was
to defund the police but here we have
the police you know being perfectly
entitled to essentially beat people up
who are peacefully protesting I mean
it's just the double standards of
politics I mean the the government in
Canada wanted so badly for this protest
to turn into or become what January 6 is
alleged to have been or become they want
it so bad for there to be violence which
I'm convinced is why they just outright
ignored the protesters
um for the three weeks they ignored them
in the hopes of getting them frustrated
enough to or just wait long enough for
it to devolve into violence because
typically that's just what happens with
protests you know the BLM protests they
don't all start violently but the longer
they go on the more likely it is you
have agitators coming in Bad actors
coming in people who just want to
exploit the opportunity to loot and and
cause Havoc it's the same thing with
with hockey um Pro not protest but
hockey celebrations they they go on long
enough they ultimately devolve into
breaking windows and looting the the
mostly peaceful but slightly fiery
protests in the U.S we didn't have them
to that extent in Canada even for the
BLM protests they remain by and large
peaceful uh they shut down streets maybe
not for three weeks but you know they
shut down streets they cause traffic
problems
um they could have easily met the same
grounds for the violent intervention
that Trudeau decided to implement on
these protesters but I I'm convinced
they just ignore them because they
wanted it to devolve and if anybody
thinks I'm exaggerating or I've taken
sides on this I have I have my own side
on this but I was there I asked the cops
has there been have there been any acts
of violence any any vandalism One Cop
said yeah there's a broken window and
then started smirking and said yeah but
it had nothing to do with the protest
another cop said yeah there was some
vandalism right across the street in
real time and I walk across the street
to see he said it was on the Senate
building and I saw nothing and I don't
know if he was joking but you know this
this was three weeks of of peaceful
protest so peaceful by the way that the
the Ottawa Council their biggest issue
with this was that there were bouncy
castles and Hot Tubs on Wellington and
it's it's unacceptable this led to
Justin Trudeau after three weeks of the
most peaceful protest declaring the
emergencies act uh you know yet again
desecrating our Constitution and rule of
law for political gain
making fools of everyone in his party
that voted for this and the new democrat
party that voted for this only to
rescind the order two days after it was
voted upon because there are now
existing laws that can deal with the
situation as though that was not always
the case beforehand everyone who's
charged with a crime there was charged
under the criminal code which
pre-existed the emergencies act
declaration but my theory they wanted it
to devolve so badly that they just said
we'll wait and we'll wait and we'll wait
and something bad will happen and when
it didn't happen and it just got
absolutely embarrassed and mocked on the
international scene and this started
generating spin-off movements across the
world they said my goodness we got to
put an end to it how do we do that let's
go to our our state-sponsored media
let's pretend that let's go back to
those alleged Nazi flags and Confederate
flags of which there were only one each
on day one both asked to leave never to
be repeated they go back to the media
say make this into something outrageous
so that we can justify using the
emergencies act they did it and even in
the violent Crackdown to end it they did
not provoke the response that they
wanted to provoke from those peaceful
protesters
but it wasn't just the Canadian
government ignoring uh the protest it's
also the mainstream media particularly
in the UK I can't talk for the for the
us but it was impossible to find this
story anywhere and it was only covered
in a few outlets and when they did cover
it it was biased no always the same the
same stories if you stand with Nazi
flags and Confederate flags and people
who desecrate the war monuments
everybody out there needs to understand
this and if you don't trust me you can
go watch 40 hours of live stream there
was exactly one image of an individual
carrying a Nazi flag and one image of an
individual carrying a Confederate flag
who for whatever the reason was the only
individual there wearing a full face
mask with sunglasses he was asked to
leave and I know the individual who
asked him to leave personally the guy
with the Nazi flag on the on the
outskirts of the protest and just
happened to have a professional
photographer three feet from him with a
three thousand dollar Cannon rig to snap
the wonderful image and those lying
politicians ran with those two singular
images to paint the narrative that this
was a racist Nazi white supremacist
overthrow the government Insurrection
protest and that's all the media ran
with and it was it was it was
mind-blowing even when the media was uh
live streaming or live reporting on the
Crackdown and they literally see police
officers
needing protesters like they like you'd
think that they were trying to soften up
a bag of hay uh the the the reporters
like well we're watching a couple of
arrests live and I was like no that's
not an arrest what you're watching
you're watching a piece you're watching
a policeman assault a peaceful protester
so the coverage was so limited so
tainted so skewed but it is exactly what
you would expect when you're talking
about fascism from the media that is
paid by the government on whom they are
supposed to report I mean basically
imagine someone who's who's supposed to
criticize their employer it won't happen
and it's an interesting point you make
we're going to go to the Q a in a few
minutes and guys remember if you want to
send in the super chat or a PayPal
that's the best way to get your question
asked but David there's something that
strikes me immediately sitting here in
London talking to you which is
you know like I have family in Ukraine
right now when the situation is
happening and they have martial law and
I'm going well there's a war going on
martial law kind of makes sense like you
need to make sure people aren't just
walking around getting killed and all
that but what we're talking about here
and this is the Striking thing is we're
sitting in London where we are now
completely free all restrictions lifted
no we came close to considering a
vaccine mandates and vaccine passports
but it didn't happen right and it's been
a few months since uh since the uh
Omicron wave started and now we're
completely free right uh the numbers in
hospitals are down the number of people
catching it is down the number of people
seriously ill is way down and our
restrictions are gone we're not wearing
masks we don't have to none of that and
the things that you are describing uh
the dictatorship as you called it and
the fascistic Tendencies of your
government they are in response to the
very same thing that we have here in
London for which we are taking no action
whatsoever and we are fine so what is
that all about
I mean I I don't it's it's a bizarre
thing that the government just doubles
down on its on its failed policies I
mean that's what that's what government
does the failed policy you can't admit
mistake because admitting mistake in
politics is an act of weakness so you
got to double down on your failed policy
the amazing thing uh if you were to just
you know overlay two graphs of coveted
hospitalizations deaths Etc if you were
to Overlay two graphs that of Canada
with that of Florida and you would see
that with or without the most Draconian
measures the graph looks pretty much the
same uh you know you might you might
think twice about your policies unless
you're the government and you've just
had this massive two-year power grab and
you don't want to give back the rights
which have now become privileges so what
do you got to do you double down double
down and then and then shift the uh
shift the attention shift the focus but
it's just it's been a cataclysmic
failure from day one we now have the
reports coming out showing that
lockdowns did nothing uh I won't get
into the face masks because I'm not I
know my limits uh but when you overlay
the graph of Florida and Canada and you
see that it was the same result
regardless of what they did you know a
responsible government would say okay
fine we thought what we were doing was
right and now we're just going to back
it all up uh an irresponsible tyrannical
regime like Justin Trudeau will say
we're doubling down we've promised a
billion taxpayer dollars to the
provinces for this vaccine passport
system while the indigenous peoples up
north don't actually have clean drinking
water but set that aside and um and we
want to keep going hard so let's
demonize this protest let's try to
trigger a January 6th type event with
these protesters so that we can come
down with even more Draconian measures
the emergencies act when that when he
does that and it doesn't exactly work
out as planned and it looks like the
Senate might have been ready to vote
down the invocation backtrack and just
make a total fool of yourself and then
go focus on the Ukraine
David do you think this marks the end of
Trudeau's prime minister
I forgot the word but Prime ministership
that's the one do you think this marks
the end of his prime minister ship or do
you think
you know that he's gonna weather this
storm like our own Boris Johnson does
with his own Shenanigans and that he's
just gonna carry on
exactly the word so yeah
I I think I did say that uh this this
emergencies act invocation is either
going to be the end of Canada
politically speaking or it's going to be
the end of Trudeau politically speaking
I I thought Trudeau was done for it
after the third re-election with the
minority government because you can't
you can't keep getting re-elected as a
minority government and then expect to
stay the leader of the party so I
thought he was done for back in
September but that requires another
election this
I think I think he he he should be
regarded as what he is politically toxic
any liberal within the party with the
slightest aspirations for leadership
should see this as the moment to to jump
on it Trudeau has desecrated our
constitution desecrated the rule of law
caused if it's not irreparable it's very
long lasting harm to Canadian financial
institutions to International trust in
Canadian financial institutions
um and he's embarrassed everyone in his
own party who spent two days debating at
the House of Commons the necessity of
this emergencies Act only so that he
could two days later say I'm rescinding
it he made fools of everyone in his
party everyone in the nvp thank goodness
he exposed the fool that is just uh that
is jagmeet Singh but he he should be
politically toxic forever and I think it
is just a matter of time before either
there's a vote of confidence and there's
going to be new elections uh and he's
out oh but but I think he's he's I think
he is done for and he should be done for
politically because he's caused
irreparable harm nationally and
internationally to Canada and now he
gets up and wants to tell Putin about
unwarranted aggression in the Ukraine I
mean the world's not stupid the people
learn from it from that people follow
the example and when they know that you
no longer have any moral Authority or
moral standing to take such positions
they're going to feel empowered to do
similar things so he it should be the
end of him politically and I think it
will be it's just going to take a few
more weeks or months to pan out you make
a good point and it's a point
particularly by Ukraine I've been making
for for some time now about the West's
moral Authority and how much we
undermine it when we fail to adhere to
our own values uh but David it's been
brilliant we've been chatting for an
hour it's flown by I really want to get
as many of our audience questions in as
possible so guys uh send them in and in
a couple of minutes time we will address
and we're going to take a quick
commercial break and we're back in a
couple of minutes to ask all your
questions to David thanks for watching
so far
hey Constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and KK get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below so see you there
guys
hey KK do you like feeling silky and
smooth like a sexual dolphin never talk
to me again what if I told you that
manscape to brought out a new and
improved lawnmower 3.0 that allows you
to be fresh and trim for the ladies down
below I'm married the last time I was
fresh and trimmed down below Jimmy
Savile was a respected children's
entertainer I'm gonna ignore that the
lawnmower has a Cutting Edge ceramic
blade which reduces the risk of having
an accident where you least want an
accident my bank account no you idiot
you know Los huevos oh right plus it's
waterproof which means you can groom in
the shower and it has an LED light so
you can really get an accurate and
precise trim x
sounds great what's the battery like 90
minutes so you can do your whole area in
about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is of course
trigger 2-0 that is trigger 2-0 that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscapes.com and use our code which is
of course trigger two zero your huevos
will thank you excellent
all right everybody welcome back we're
going to ask your questions of Viva
fried let's bring him back in Anton here
we go we've got a bunch of stuff coming
in uh let's fire away so the first one
is a very good question and it's from SK
and they ask Quest quick question for
Viva do you think conservatism is on the
rise in Canada after the catastrophic
Trudeau government I I don't know what
conservatism means anymore but if I
think do I think that people who support
freedom of speech oppose censorship and
believe that constitutional rights
should have some value is on the rise
yes and I hope so I do also
unfortunately think that what I see on
the rise are people thinking everything
is Justified if it's purportedly for the
greater good so your your freedom of
Mobility can be you know whisked away
like that if it's for the greater good
my only response to that is uh the
individual rights is the greater good
and to quote Ayn Rand there is no
minority smaller than the individual and
if you don't support individual rights
you basically don't support minority
rights whatsoever
just to just to add to that question do
you not worry that I've used the phrase
Pandora's Box before
do you not worry that we've opened a
Pandora's Box here and that now it's
just going to be another government tool
well I I am worried about them like it's
exactly what we saw or it's analogous to
what we saw happen in the United States
with the impeachment proceedings you
know these these exceptional laws these
exceptional recourses that destabilize
governments and Nations themselves
they're supposed to be limited to the
most egregious exceptional circumstances
declaring the uh the emergencies Act is
the um it followed the war measures act
invoking the war measures Act was
supposed to be done during an act of you
know during war during some form of
absolute unquestionable National crisis
if it's questionable it's probably not
going to satisfy it if the impeachment
is supposed to you know it's supposed to
have been sacred and it was just it was
just poured out it was it was it was
bastardized in its application to the
point where now it's like hey well it's
just another tool of government the
emergencies act likewise was never
supposed to be just another tool in the
Box it was supposed to be the only break
in case of emergencies acts above the
box and Justin Trudeau after three weeks
of failed leadership demonizing good
peace-loving Canadians time to time to
break out the ax when I haven't even
used the toolbox it's a really good
point now we've got a slightly
light-hearted question from with the
five Canadian dollars he says Viva I
love your spirit I just wanted to
confirm if you are indeed the love child
of Richard Gere and Geraldo Rivera I
have gotten Richard Gere as a younger
person when my hair was shorter I've
gotten Richard Gere never seen it
Geraldo Rivera I can sort of understand
with the facial hair but uh I am not I
am
Barbara since that was a quick one I'll
do another the sort of slightly
lighthearted one there is everyone why
is everyone banging on about Justin
Trudeau being Castro's son I don't get
it uh and some uh yeah well but anyway
it's on Candy but you have to be careful
with those images it's very easy to
slightly alter to make things look more
like them but the bottom line Trudeau's
mother had a history a known history and
she had a known history with with Castro
as well
uh that okay perfect and icky Ike says
uh uh he sort of makes that joke
initially but he's got a serious
question at the end of it says do you
think that Justin Castro as he put it
he's finally following in his father's
uh cubanadian footsteps just ignore that
part of it I think you've addressed it
but he what he asks is a more serious
question is are more authoritarian moves
coming up do you think well I don't
think so I think he's I think Trudeau
really uh I don't know if jump the shark
is the right expression he really
crossed the line here uh and I and when
civil rights associations in Canada that
are traditionally you know more more
left than left uh announced their filing
suit uh you know he's gone too far and I
just read in the chat apparently if if
Tamara Lich the organizer who's been
held in jail for going on a week for
mischief charges uh if if it is in fact
true that she has another hearing on
Monday I think that's earlier than when
they initially uh said they were going
to have one yeah I think everybody's
starting to feel the pressure here
because they crossed the line with with
this and everybody I think understands
that I it's arguable whether or not what
Justin Trudeau did in terms of freezing
bank accounts with no court order no no
no probable cause no due process it's
arguable whether or not that caused a
run on the banks which is why he also
felt pressure to rescind this but I
think everybody appreciates what he did
really caused a very big tear in the
fabric of Canadian society and Canadian
economy that they have to now start
pulling back and stitching up and not
not tearing further hmm
uh David James Robinson uh asks does
viva think the current Russia Ukraine
crisis is going to give Trudeau enough
cover uh in Brackets distraction to get
away with what he did they're gonna the
media is certainly gonna do it and help
him help him do it uh but no I mean the
thing is also there is an element of the
Canadian subsidized media that is even
turning on Trudeau but it's got to get
so politically popular that they can
call it out for what it is the media
across the globe are going to focus on
the Ukraine Russia conflict they're
going to Hype it up as much as they can
because it's good for their business
um but I think unfortunately for Trudeau
that the the independent press with
broader reach and more influence than
Legacy Media are not going to forget it
and they're not going to let up on it
and it's not going to go away anytime
soon and and I think no that this will
be a temporary distraction but at the
end of the day he there will be
political accounts that will be held for
what uh for what they just did here
and on on a similar subject June hope
says is it legal to act on a policy
that's not law and hasn't been ratified
I.E freezing bank accounts was that in
your assessment uh if there is ever an
investigation into or some kind of court
hearing about it will that be found to
to be unconstitutional and unlawful in
Canada so no legal advice this is my own
personal opinion because I've stated it
already it was absolutely unjustified to
have invoked the emergencies act it did
not meet any of the criteria I believe
any reasonably uh objective Court would
strike down the Declaration uh of the
emergencies act now a separate I'm this
is again this is not even legal advice
these are just questions that I would be
asking as a lawyer and potentially as
someone whose bank account might have
been frozen the emergencies act uh
declaration and the directives that
Trudeau wanted to implement under the
Declaration which needed to get approved
by both the House of Commons and the
Senate within seven sitting days of
declaring the emergencies act it never
got ratified he rescinded it before it
could either get ratified or struck down
by the Senate so the question is it's
nice that the government promises
immunity to Banks who carry out these
objectives after pressure from the
government but if the Declaration was
never ratified I would ask myself and
possibly a court whether or not their
immunity was ever conferred and if it
wasn't they might not be immune for
having arbitrarily unilaterally in the
absence of a court order with no due
process Frozen bank accounts at the
direction and behest of the government
itself it's arguable whether or not they
actually benefit from immunity and I
would I would look to the courts to
question that and to provide an answer
for that but that's a question I would
be asking because it's a real question
I'm following on from that uh Texas
Terry ask Will protesters in Canada
continue to be subject to financial
penalties including Frozen bank accounts
because there's a lot of them who've
just paid a one-off payment I think was
it after February the 15th
and will they continue to face penalties
do you think or will this you know
gradually go away well so the as far as
I understand uh the bank accounts that
were frozen there were 206 of them
apparently according to Christian
Freeland 206 accounts were arbitrarily
Frozen uh they uh consisted of the
organizers of the protest and truck
drivers or people who Park their car on
Wellington so I presume they took
pictures of license plates went to the
banks and said freeze the accounts my
understanding is the accounts have been
unfrozen and I've had discussions with
two organizers or two people involved in
the protest who have had their bank
accounts unfrozen now so I don't think
there's going to be any more freezing of
account I think that caused a very
serious problem both in terms of a
potential Bank Run and just
International confidence in the Canadian
banking system now they work at the
behest of the government with immunity
uh but as far as the other charges go
yeah everyone who face charges everyone
who got charged with Mischief
obstruction whatever those are criminal
charges that they're going to have to
deal with I don't think they're going to
get uh revoked by the issuing
authorities
um but I I mean we'll see how the courts
come down on these things because some
of these mischief charges uh yeah so
when the when the coronavirus hit
covered hit the UK and restrictions were
put in the first thing our government
did is say oh you don't want to use cash
we're not going to use cash because
that's person-to-person transaction and
the virus can be spread with the cash
and blah blah blah we're going to get
rid of cash everything's on card now
immediately my head my the alarm in my
head went off because I went hang on a
second that's just another way for you
to track US that's another way for you
to control us and actually
once you've become wholly reliant on a
bank account all they need to do is
freeze it and then you're done there's
nothing you can do you can't go anywhere
that you don't have access to cash
people don't understand how dangerous
this is
have they got rid of cash in Canada and
do you think that this was part of a
strategy
so they haven't gotten rid of cash in
Canada people don't appreciate how
vulnerable they are until it happens to
them but then they you know they
reassure themselves well I'd never be
I'd never occupy downtown Ottawa so do
it to them and they deserve it because
I'd never be there yeah wait until the
government next government doesn't like
BLM protests and they say oh you're at a
BLM protest Frozen bank accounts good
luck paying your mortgage good luck
buying food it's a human rights
violation in my opinion because you are
effectively trying to starve a person to
death and that's what they tried to do
with the protest they tried to freeze
them out starve them out physically by
you know not allowing them to bring gas
into for their trucks and then when it
was over they try to basically
financially ruin and effectively starve
and remove from society the people whose
bank accounts they froze
um it's dangerous the precedent is there
and worse than that I think the
government you know tried to push
forward some legislation which would
expand the powers of Finn track which is
like some it's a way of tracking foreign
money uh that some people hypothesize
that that was the end game and they
might have gotten away with that we'll
see but people are now very sensitive to
the fact that you know it's nice to have
a bank card it's nice to have a credit
card with money in your account but now
that we've just seen the government can
come in overnight with no court order
freeze it all people realize now that
they're vulnerable and maybe people are
waking up to I'm not going to go with
the cryptocurrency stuff because I still
don't understand it but valuing cash and
valuing not having all your eggs in one
Bank basket yeah you're right and you
know it was genuinely because you know
you read the stories and you don't quite
it doesn't hit you but we we do these
calls with our top supporters and one of
them she sent a hundred bucks to to
these protesters and she said she spent
the whole time basically being terrified
because she's a single real retired
person no friends or family nearby her
income is a pension and she basically
was in a position where if the
government or the bank had decided to
freeze her she's literally going to
starve to death right and yeah
and they knew it with these truckers
they have a community so you know
there's a community that helps them get
through the week where their bank
accounts were frozen but I I said at the
time you know like some of these
measures were unconstitutional but the
idea of retroactively criminalizing
Behavior which was not criminal at the
time it was conducted which would have
been the donations to a federally
Incorporated registered not-for-profit I
mean the idea to retroactively
criminalize anyone who donated to what
the government recognized and and
certified as a not-for-profit would have
been over the top and it would have
violated another provision of our
Charter section 11g which says you can
only be convicted of a crime if at the
time of the act or Omission it was
illegal so I was never quite as
concerned about that uh but I understand
that people were and that people were
making a run on the banks I've been told
I just had no definitive evidence you
know I I never had the bank say you
can't take out money but I've heard
people say it but yeah it's it's it
instills Terror in the citizens which
might have been the goal but it
destabilizes the financial and economic
system itself on a national and
international level who's going to want
to do business with Canadian Banks going
forward they can freeze your account
they can ask for information on your
clients who's going to want to do
business with Canada I mean very much on
this point David very much on this point
Robin still says can you can you explain
the exact damage these Bank freezing
Banks freezing accounts Etc caused to
Canada relative to the International
Community you alluded to it earlier but
I think a lot of us who are not you know
fully into the law of this and also the
financial relations between Banks and
different countries what will be the
impact uh for Canada and the Canadian
Financial system out of everything
that's happened I mean it's tough to
measure but if you're a business person
looking to do business in Canada and you
might be conservatively aligned you
might be the my pillow guy or you're
going to want to open up a bank account
and do business in Canada now uh is is
any foreign country going to look at
Canada like a beacon of democracy or are
they going to look at it as a as a a
symbol of the same tyranny you'd see in
North Korea nobody's running to invest
in North Korea because when the
government can just usurp your assets
with no court order no nothing and then
immunize the federally regulated
institutions for their conduct who in
their right mind would do that so I
think the the damages uh it's it's
immeasurable but it's also intangible
but it's very real and it's why I think
there has to be very serious political
blowback for this because this precedent
needs to be struck down and shun upon
going forward otherwise it's good that
Trudeau did it and didn't get away with
it but if the rest of Canadian
politicians say it's it's something
we're prepared to accept will Canada can
enjoy being relegated to a second-tier
nation when it comes to stability for
financial investments and business going
forward setting aside the whole
Constitution side of things
have you got a question I can do another
one quickly so uh by the way a lot of
love for you in the chat and in the
messages
there was one person who said I was full
of [ __ ] and I I genuinely want to know
what I said I need evidence not
accusation so if I yeah but unless he
sends US money we're not reading out his
[ __ ] question
I'm kidding no uh we always love people
to challenge what we are saying or the
guests are saying so if people want to
uh push back against things that are
being said and send us a message we'll
happily read that out but what I was
saying was there's also a lot of support
somebody says you should be appointed to
the Canadian Senate uh the the question
that I think worries all of us as
creators online people who cover this
stuff and who who sometimes take a
heterodox view of things uh this was
from homemade creative and send us some
money on PayPal says do you expect
Trudeau's government to try to crack
down on disinformation by working with
big Tech to shut down descent I.E your
live streams on YouTube no well
I I still believe in the Streisand
effects so you know good good luck doing
something that's so egregious that
there's a sufficient network of lawyers
out there who would fight it legally uh
influencers who would fight it on social
media they're trying to do it in a more
Insidious way and it's we've been
talking about it it's either bill c-10
or C it's one of these bills I forget I
think it's C10 which was to regulate the
internet under the broadcast act and to
regulate the internet the way the
government currently regulates
television and radio and so there was
this move to put forward this bill chat
can correct me I think it's Bill c-10
but it was to treat online platforms if
they're sufficiently broadcast-ish to
treat them like broadcasters under the
broadcast act and to create all these
these these these onerous government uh
obligations in terms of content uh being
Canadian you know fines yada yada they
wanted to do that and that law um that
that draft or the what is it called the
bill made it past the House of Commons
which is liberal and NDP always looking
for another way to control and censor uh
and it there was an election and it
didn't make it past the Senate but
that's the way they're going to go about
doing it they're not going to go down
like uh you know Hammer bands and
whatever first of all I respect the
rules on YouTube I respect the law
people don't like the fact that I
respect the law so much when I went to
the protest I wasn't looking to get into
trouble I made sure to get on video
every police officer that I asked if I'm
allowed to go here because if I'm not
I'm not going to fight and I'm not going
to sneak in uh when it comes to YouTube
I know the rules I sometimes don't agree
with the rules but I respect them so
they want if they want to try to pick
that fight uh I think the I've I've laid
the groundwork for a solid opposition
legally and uh influentially uh
influentially I don't know if that's a
word but um no they're trying they're
just trying through the legislative
process come down with hate speech laws
so Hong Kong ban it shut down the
channel because it violates YouTube's
terms of service for hate speech because
Hong Kong is now hate speech in Canada
um regulate channels of a sufficient
size call them broadcasters and impose
these onerous obligations to stifle
their popularity which is merit-based in
order to try to push it back to the
Legacy Media which is government uh
induced so there's always the concern
we've hedged our bets a lot we're on
locals Robert Barnes and I
vivabarnslaw.locals.com I'm on Rumble as
well and Rumble is the up-and-coming
competitor Free Speech competitor of
YouTube which is why the Legacy Media in
Canada is going after them so hard
but uh look there's the fear there's the
David Mamet expression every fear hides
a wish because you know let them try to
do it it'll only make the problem worse
uh and then also Donald Trump expression
hope for the best plan for the worst so
head your bets don't put it all in one
basket
and on that note Ali Snyder who is a
fantastic supporter of trigonometry
shout out to ali uh goes what gives you
hope for the future of Canada and would
you consider running for office again
again I'm not sure uh I'll tell you why
I'm not sure I at one point when I was
naive enough to think that I could
actually win the night of the election I
was like holy crap if I actually win I
have to stop doing what I'm doing now I
have to go become a a useless wheel in
the Rusted machine of government where
I'm gonna like I'm gonna do my best to
spin and nothing's gonna happen uh it's
it's what I disliked about the practice
of law is It's Paper pushing it's a lot
of stuff that doesn't ultimately get
anywhere and doesn't actually ultimately
change anything and you know
for all his great speeches
conservative party's done nothing to to
attenuate the the regression of Canada
so I was actually the night of I was
like What if I what if I I might
actually win and everything I love doing
I can no longer do I think I can be more
impactful from the outside uh and so I'm
I might not run again but we'll see
Never Say Never And I have to see where
I am in the future in any event and hope
for Canada
um
that's a tough one because I I get very
dis I feel a lot of Despair sometimes
seeing good intelligent people say we
want this listening to daytime radio
ostensibly saying we want this people
calling and saying I'm going to feel
unsafe if they don't have vaccine
passports at restaurants I don't want to
take the masks off everybody's selfish
when I have people threatening to you
know docs and and and and and and harass
people who donated to this Convoy
because some people don't like this
charity I don't have much hope for
Canada or
um I won't say the future at large but I
I I get concerned what I think is
inspiring in all of this I get a lot of
private messages I have a lot of
one-on-one conversations with people who
have had enough and who see it going in
a way that even they don't like sure it
took two and a half years to get here
but the pendulum swings it it does swing
and you know there is the old expression
you can vote yourself into tyranny but
you have to fight yourself out of it
we that that's why I think we're not yet
beyond the point of swinging back and it
will swing back in my mind it's just a
question of how long at what cost and
you know will it will it swing far
enough back will it swing too far back
will you have the same problems on the
other end
but people are starting to get fed up
with it and people are starting to
awaken to it this trucker Convoy has
awakened a lot of people who really did
not appreciate how much and the degree
to which the media lies so there's that
and ultimately
it was the most peaceful Human Rights
Movement protest in a long time people
saw it people got inspired by it so that
itself should be inspired inspirational
David that this is such a great message
to to wrap up on we've had lots of
brilliant questions we couldn't quite
squeeze all of them in uh but we do have
the question that we always ask all of
our guests and you David haven't had
advanced warning of this so uh let's see
what you say to this which is what is
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society and it can be absolutely
anything doesn't have to be have to be
related to what we've talked about today
what is the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be and we
might okay I like it and by the way just
everyone knows I never ask for questions
before doing interviews because I I like
it to be fresh and I think it's
disingenuous but um the one thing we're
not talking about or possibly not
talking about enough is parental rights
and we're sort of talking about it in
Canada but a lot of stuff is slipping
under the radar it's it's an offshoot of
what happens when the government tells
you they can lock you in your your house
they ultimately come in and tell you
what you can do with your kids and what
you have to do with your kids and the
government comes in and thinks in as
much as they thought they were the
parents of every Canadian over the last
two years when Justin Trudeau says we've
got your backs we're there to help you
when the government thinks they are the
parents of adult citizens voting
citizens
when they start thinking that they are
the actual parents of the children of
those adult citizens you start getting
into very very very dangerous territory
and in Quebec they're talking about
um revoking effectively what's known as
parental uh the supremacy of Parental
Authority basically that parents decide
what's best for their kids and not the
government
and we've seen this envelope being
pushed in covid where you have Trudeau
appealing to and reaching out to kids
directly you have government messaging
saying kids can go get medical
interventions without even having to run
it by their parents that's what I think
people need to start talking about
because once the government thinks they
know what's best for kids above and
beyond the parents saving aside obvious
examples of abuse and objective examples
of abuse once that happens and once
parents no longer
um I was gonna say own it once parents
no longer have the absolute authority
over the essential decision making for
their children that's uh that's a line
that you can't come back from so I think
people need to be talking about that
more in Quebec I don't know if the law
was actually passed or the amendment
which basically now no longer recognizes
the supremacy of Parental Authority but
it's we've been pushing the envelope as
to uh the government taking over
parental responsibilities for kids I
appreciate the government has to protect
against abuse and the government has to
ensure certain basic needs and
Necessities are met but um
what was I going to say I forgot I
forgot the quote that I had but but but
yeah we I think we'll hear what you're
saying which is and look this is a big
part of the conversation more broadly
about this whole woke uh agenda which is
are your kids being brainwashed from the
age of five by the education system and
do you have a right to go in and find
out what's going on what are they being
taught do you have a voice in America
there's obviously been a lot of pushback
against that I think you're absolutely
right to raise that as an issue because
you know my wife is we're about to have
our first child as I said and you know
that's that's probably my biggest
concern uh behind World War III kicking
off uh where I'm from uh no no it's it's
the the indoctrination is I mean it's
one thing that so long as you have
discussions with your kids and you know
what's going on you can have those
discussions but when they start you know
when you see Family Law Courts taking
kids away from parents because the
parents didn't do what the court says
they have to do in terms of medical
Intervention when the when that's when
it really starts getting dangerously and
scarily orwellian but no I think that
the discussion as to parental rights
being virtually absolute oh what I was
going to say was the government is the
necessary evil but you need as little of
it as possible so you know the
government should be there to protect
kids from outright abuse but when it
gets into the gray zone of parenting as
I say if the government thinks that they
have the black and the white answers
that Trump Gray Zone parenting well the
government is never going to own my kids
period by the way sorry I've been
hogging the mic a little bit but since
we've we've you've given us some of your
time just one more question for my own
Indulgence which is the second amendment
a lot of people talk in America about
how the guarantee of freedom is the
Second Amendment and if if only you know
the UK had had the Second Amendment or
Germany had a second amendment or
Austria Australia New Zealand Italy
France the all of these countries that
have implemented uh these Draconian
rules at one point another the
government would have been afraid to to
cross these boundaries but you guys you
have guns in Canada you have private gun
ownership right no gun ownership uh in
Canada is excessively difficult to
obtain and
unlicensed Firearms are only long arms
so hunting rifles because basically in
Canada there's no Second Amendment it's
you can own it for hunting and pretty
much only for hunting for target
practice or for sports uh not for not
for self-defense and not for home
defense and Small Arms you have to have
a special license for which is like
pistols uh it's called there's a
specific license for small arms which
are restricted firearms uh so we have no
no effective second amendment in Canada
and you see the you see the net coming
down on that also during the pandemic
Justin Trudeau passed what's called an
order in council which is no legislative
process no debate it's in the regulation
itself to ban you know thousands of
types of assault rifle Firearms uh you
see that net coming down too and that's
another interesting progression of my
life uh people say it you know America
is what it is because of the Second
Amendment and the government but for the
Second Amendment would have done exactly
what Australia did you never know you
you can't really tell
um but I have I have grown to appreciate
the arguments for second amendment
rights uh especially when you see in
Canada that you can't even own firearms
for home defense uh it's it's a bizarre
thing where the government strips you of
your ability to protect yourself
criminalizes your ability to protect
yourself and then you know takes
political sides that you you can see how
things can go south very quickly but no
if anyone thinks Canada we have second
amendment anything like the U.S
absolutely not I took the firearm safety
course for the long arms it's you have
to take a two-day course uh you have to
pass a test if you want to acquire one
you got to get permission from your
spouse you have to have a background
check it takes months and that's just
for an unrestricted hunting rifle for
the for the smaller arms it's uh it's a
totally separate Beast
David it's been an absolute pleasure the
the hour and a half or so is completely
flown by what a joy um if people want to
find you online if people want to
discover your work where would be the
best place to do that so YouTube and
Rumble I'm under Viva fry Twitter I'm
Viva fry that's the only one that has
the v in front of it and then I'm on
getter Viva fry if you want I have that
thing with Barnes where we're on this
Robert Barnes is an American lawyer we
do weekly live streams and weekly uh
interviews with a guest that's on
vivabarnslaw.locals.com that's our sort
of Facebook page behind a paywall but
there's a lot of stuff that's open for
all supporters not just paid supporters
but that's a place for great exclusive
content and discussion that we can't
have on on the YouTubes but it's
basically vivofry you'll find me
everywhere uh YouTube and Rumble
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
for joining us David and thank you all
for watching and listening we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
conversation like this one or raw show
the next one is tonight all of them go
out at 7 pm UK time and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care thanks for joining thanks for
commenting and we'll see you very soon
guys
hey concertin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard hitting SATA
plus my handsome jawline whatever takes
away from your hairline but if you do
love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and KK get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
hey KKK do you like feeling silky and
smooth like a sexual dolphin never talk
to me again what if I told you that
manscape to brought out a new and
improved lawn mower 3.0 that allows you
to be fresh and trim for the ladies down
below I'm married the last time I was
fresh and trimmed down below Jimmy
Savile was a respected children's
entertainer I'm gonna ignore that the
lawnmower has a Cutting Edge ceramic
blade which reduces the risk of having
an accident where you least want an
accident my bank account no you idiot
you know
Los huevos oh right plus it's waterproof
which means you can groom in the shower
and it has an LED light so you can
really get an accurate and precise trim
excellent sounds great what's the
battery like 90 minutes so you can do
your whole area in about
seven recharges to take advantage of
this incredible offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is a Force
Trigger 2-0 that is trigger 2-0 that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscapes.com and use our code which is
of course trigger to zero your huevos
will thank you